previously on TV sins pardon my french
but you're an [ __ ] look I love HBO
you love HBO can we all agree that they
are way up their own ass with this
pretentious two minutes of opening theme
nonsense I feel like the Sun is wearing
sunglasses here and the Sun should never
be this cool I found this intro severely
boring until this moment but now I have
to ask is sex during construction a good
idea I would think there would be some
sort of warning label on the 3d printer
box about waiting 12 to 15 hours after
creation before strenuous activities
maybe I'm just sexing wrong usually
intro to a show should give you some
idea what you're in for but based on
this I can't tell if it's Minority
Report meets Gunsmoke or a Glidden
commercial I spy with my little eye this
fly will try to walk this eye and I
simply reply why dog why tell us what
you think of your world some people
choose to see the ugliness in this world
the disarray hey he said you can lose
the accent aren't you supposed to take
orders stop it with the drawl you
wascally will rot now the first time I
plated Whitehead family was here we went
fishing your family hey honey let's pack
up the tykes and go fishing in Westworld
yeah there's racism mass homicides and
rape fantasies going on but the trout
are really biting right whiskey
about it what are you doing any good
sitting in that bottle at first I was
gonna send a bartender who refuses to 10
bar but since everything he says was
written by a writing team this sin lands
firmly on the west-world writers room
stay put Delores character says don't
follow me when we all know they are
going to follow them cliche I reckon
she's still warm enough
I'm judging for it oh yeah well I'm
judging it out of this show for being
gross enough to include this launch what
if I told you that you can't hurt the
newcomers I'd say you might be right but
it doesn't change the fact that this
entire Park is the deathtrap sure you
can possibly keep the weapons safe but
these people will be climbing actual
mountains walking and raging rivers and
riding fully functioning horses I'd say
there are at least 50 people that die in
West world each year and no amount of
expositional burn aeration is going to
change mama we all love the newcomers
every new person I meet reminds me how
lucky I am to be alive I really wish I
could appreciate how this is shot but
instead you know I'm watching people be
murdered and raped it's not even
lunchtime also sweet shot broke but if
you're gonna do a reflection you should
probably reverse the image since you
know that's how reflections worked
Groundhog Day - the darkest hog wait are
they assembling this horse by hand this
echo on an assembly line makes it appear
that these animals are produced in rooms
but the credits and common sense
indicate that machines do it
unprofessional much I get that these
aren't humans exactly but do you make
out with company equipment on company
time at your job ok fine but do you do
it in a glass room where everyone can
see you what [ __ ] designed this
elevator panel the information behind
the b8 - graphic is covered up and it
seems like it's pretty important
information it's also repetitive
considering that the top of the panel
also says the destination this space is
basically the size of a city block and
the team isn't walking in ankle-deep
water so where was all that water coming
from these conversations when no guests
are around seem completely unnecessary
would it be easy enough for the hosts to
have proximity sensors on visiting
guests and adjust their actions to
what's required of moving into their
story there is no reason for these two
to have the same conversation every
morning if no one's around to hear it
when the memories and the actions could
be programmed internally once the good
words Hedy on this narrative loop Teddy
is distracted and doesn't follow Dolores
but as the camera pans Teddy is suddenly
here before you say oh this could be
anyone dressed like Teddy with his
beaming jawline and that could be seen
from space I won't believe it because
Teddy's guy pals are suddenly gone as
well it's ok continuity department there
are so many narratives to keep track of
and the audience is so perplexed you
could be forgiven for thinking no one
would notice ha forgiveness show
confirms that it actually take place on
Tatooine considering I can't think of a
reason other than two suns that these
two would both be casting such
pronounced double shadows so what they
happened
I don't know but later we watch for come
in and ask Abernathy to access a
previous configuration to discover where
the host became corrupted so the fact
that it isn't happening now can only be
linked to a purposeful tension building
scheme that is super work it because
this show is creepy as goddamn hell we
saw a complete immersion in a hundred
interconnected narratives a relentless
experience
I mean who told this guy to deliver
lines as if he were shredding a Les Paul
I sort of love it but also calm down and
maybe stop giving 110 percent making
everyone else look bad or good or
something there's so much it's an
unscripted sneeze I want to know about
it but what about an unscripted attack
on a host how do their computing
algorithms know the difference between a
narrative glitch versus the panic and
horror when say the man in black murders
and memes for evil pleasures certainly
not every moment of a host begging for
its life is scripted in an approved
narrative apparently the flies in West
world are all programmed to crawl toward
the hosts eyes for maximum dramatic
effect then no one respects them more
than men but at some point no one
respects them more than I Teresa would
be better at cinemasins than me I'm
saying should I feel this need to have a
breakdown you want to leverage it for
your career listen changing on the card
is no man would you Joe has the audacity
to make office politics a central plot
line to the episode without even once
bringing in Michael Scott anything
getting sweet on me well can't you be in
half Cornhusker Joe has time for this
I'll admit the method here is a little
unconventional but it didn't hurt a
guest does the company that creates this
immersion world pay for the guests
counseling after they witness an
unscripted mass murder because right
technically their physical bodies aren't
hurt but I would easily bet that there
were many wounds unseen that need care
honestly this type of line in a show
only reminds me how far we've hit to go
and it comes to validating emotional
wounds and how they tremor through our
being and affect every system just as
much as a physical wound can maybe more
and this host comes out of the creation
goo he clearly has genitalia yet when we
see the host being dipped in the credits
it's true this man has no cure could be
a different stage of development but
don't those parts have to be formed all
the way through my guess is you just
didn't want a penis in your opening
credits and to that I say free the peen
this thing's so wide you too embarrassed
to use you have not appeared a product
of first you might think this Ford V
Bernard conversation is about the
mistakes of evolution and so we skip
right over this line but the show is
hinting at something much deeper which I
happen to know but I won't spoil for you
because I'm not an ass sees a host
anyway these little Easter eggs are
peppered in this pilot and damn it if
that isn't a brilliant little bit of
story building that deserves us in all
oh yes seems like maybe now would be a
great time to not stay put I mean if you
had a choice which of course you don't
but still the amount of repairs this
world must require before a narrative
loop repeats it mind blow
sure this discount Fast Five bank heist
will result in having to repair host
after terrible wounds but also how do
you match the paint colors and spindle
grain for a banister like this that's
where the real magic is no matter how
the business Wow West world steals the
TV sends model without even
acknowledging us the lesson is but
here's the thing how did this not happen
sooner the guests know they're safe so
every single one of these varmints would
be trying to play hero and take out the
bad guy right this thing makes it seem
like this one guests ruin their entire
plan that would basically be every day
at West world the idea that you could
control storylines at all is laughable
you don't know so clearly defines my
state of mind and I feel its words so
deeply to my core that I give it ten
more sins out of spite
even knowing each ding is another brick
in my cell keeping me captive and
cutting me off from everything good and
decent of this world now that's good
badger milk they're probably watching me
well let them let them see what kind of
a person I am I'm not even gonna SWAT
that fly I hope they are watching
they'll see they'll see and they don't
know and they'll say well she wouldn't
even have a
go ahead make my day you think I'm gonna
sign off on this
homicidal thing going back into service
well they opened Disneyland in 1956
nothing much in heaven but John's the
Pirates the Caribbean breaks down the
Pirates don't eat the tourists
[Music]
after Warner Oh No
Dolores we're just here to use the
bathroom
no one's gonna leave oh that's okay